earlier this week i told you that rudy
giuliani
and john eastman two former donald trump
lawyers and republican senator lindsey
graham have all been subpoenaed by a
court in the state of georgia and it's
become very common for
republicans to ignore subpoenas from
congress to appear before the january 6
committee but ignoring a subpoena from a
court is a very different thing well
we've now heard from republican senator
lindsey graham he says he's not going to
cooperate with the georgia trump
election probe now importantly some of
you wrote to me and said how can lindsay
get away with this this isn't he going
to be thrown in jail for contempt of
court understand lindsay's not saying
he's going to ignore it he's saying he's
going to fight it he's going to try to
fight the subpoena senator lindsey
graham reports reuters will not comply
with a subpoena issued by a grand jury
in georgia investigating trump's
attempts to overturn the results of the
2020 elections quote senator graham
plans to go to court challenge the
subpoena and expects to prevail said i
guess two of his attorneys they say
graham was well within his rights to
discuss with state officials the
processes and procedures around
administering elections
what they're referring to is that graham
called
and
you know
it was very clear he was trying to
strong-arm georgia into flipping the
results but what they're calling it is a
discussion about procedures
very benign way to refer to it the grand
jury also subpoenaed rudy giuliani and
others the grand jury was selected in
may to look at evidence in a probe
launched after trump was recorded on a
phone call pressuring state officials to
overturn the results graham's attorney
said in the statement that the senator
was being called simply as a witness in
what they call a fishing expedition any
information from an interview or
deposition with senator graham would
immediately be shared with the january 6
committee they don't like that
and he is going to try to fight the
subpoena now
if he tries to fight the subpoena and
loses and a court says
you have to respond to the subpoena
and he doesn't he would then be in
contempt of court that is not where we
are right now if the court decides he
must comply and he doesn't it will
become a legal issue for him unlikely i
have to tell you that he will end up
arrested because he's not again he's not
a subject or a target of the
investigation he's merely a witness he
still could be held in contempt he could
face daily fines if he ignores it it's
not likely that he's going to be
imprisoned and if he still
didn't pay the fines that are assigned
to him for ignoring the subpoena then
his assets could be seized but it is
very unlikely that lindsay's actually
going to get himself arrested
that's where we are right now uh of
course it would be great if everybody
just complied and they could tell us
everything we need to know and it would
be very clear that everybody's innocent
nobody did anything wrong and then we
could just all move on with our lives
but instead they are obstructing and
impeding and trying to get in the way of
these investigations at every turn i
will remind you my opinion remains
that it is more likely that if there are
going to be big time charges even
against trump which i don't think is
particularly likely but if it's going to
happen
i believe it's far more likely to come
from the georgia investigation than from
the january 6th investigation and i've
given the reasons why already
and
that's where my mind remains obviously
if they don't get people to comply with
subpoenas it will be much more difficult
to build these cases we will have more
on all of these stories on the david
pakman show instagram which can be found
at david pakman show
one of our sponsors is emmy
hands down some of the best ramen
noodles i've had just like any instant
ramen you pop emmy into the microwave or
on the stovetop for a few minutes and
it's ready to go but what makes amy
different is that it is packed with 21
grams of protein lower in sodium 100
percent plant-based with 18 grams of
fiber for digestive health and it tastes
excellent
so many of the other ramens are bland
simple artificial imi uses high quality
ingredients and recipes you get a zing
of flavor i've never had with any
instant ramen emmy comes in amazing
flavors like spicy beef
tom yum shrimp and black garlic chicken
if you try emmy and don't love it
you get your money back you'll get five
dollars off when you go to emmyeats.com
pacman and use the code pacman at
checkout the link is down below